For a movie about dolls made out of plastic,
"Barbie" shows an unexpected heart and humanity.
If you were thrown by the big themes in this
story about toys, don't worry. We've got you.
Warning: Spoilers for "Barbie" ahead!
"Barbie" begins with Margot Robbie's
Barbie in Barbieland, the fantastical,
pastel-colored feminist utopia and home to every
Barbie who has ever lived. There's also Issa Rae's
President Barbie, Hari Nef's Doctor Barbie,
Alexandra Shipp's Author Barbie, and so many
others. There are Kens, too. They're all named
Ken, including Ryan Gosling's Ken. Every day,
Barbie has the best day of her life, while
Ken just hopes Barbie will look his way. In
Barbieland, Barbies are just being Barbie,
building one another up with praise and
support and love, while Kens pine on the
outskirts, trying to outshine one another
in the hopes of getting some attention
or respect. It is a never-ending cycle.
But one day, Robbie Barbie's idyllic little
routine begins to crumble with strange,
unfamiliar symptoms. Barbie discovers the issues
she's facing, including cellulite
and pervasive thoughts of death…
"Do you guys ever think about dying?"
…are the result of the tether between
Barbieland and the real world. Basically
the Barbies in Barbieland are tied to the
humans who play with them in the real world.
Whatever child is playing with this particular
Barbie is struggling with more complex issues,
and they're poisoning her otherwise
perfect existence. The only way for
her to restore herself to factory settings
is to physically go into the real world,
a place that the residents of Barbieland
have some major misconceptions about.
Once she traverses the theoretical wormhole
between the two realms with her stowaway
Ken in tow, Barbie is immediately struck by the
power structure in the real world. Simply put,
men rule the world here, and women do not, a
paradigm shift that perturbs Barbie but intrigues
Ken. If that culture shock wasn't enough, when
she finally finds Sasha, the young girl Barbie
saw in her visions as the disaffected child
causing her issues, she is stunned to discover
that she and her Gen-Z friends hate Barbie. She's
shaken by the passionate, damning indictment they
inflict upon her, noting Barbie's toxic
cultural footprint, crass consumerism,
and noxious effect on beauty standards, and by
extension women's mental wellness, over half a
century. At her lowest point, Barbie is kidnapped
by Mattel agents at the order of their CEO.
Everyone at Mattel just wants Barbie to
get back in a box and teleport back home.
"Ken isn't something we're worried about."
But soon her and Ken's presence has the
same effect on the real world Sasha's
cynicism has had on Barbie. Barbie flees and
is saved by Sasha's mother, Gloria, a Mattel
employee who is revealed to be the real cause of
Barbie's plight. She had been playing with her
and her daughter's old dolls in an attempt to
reconnect with her grouchy, disaffected child.
Barbie convinces them to join her back in
Barbieland, hoping the paisley majesty of
her home will inspire Sasha to be less
jaded and to stop hating Barbie as a
cultural icon. Perhaps it'll help repair Sasha
and Gloria's relationship in the process and,
at least on a smaller scale, fulfill some
of the destiny Barbie had thought already
was cemented before her unfortunate sojourn
to the real world. When they actually make it
back to Barbieland, they discover it is
not what it once was. It is now…Kendom.
Robbie's Barbie has no real allies among
the dolls, and doesn't feel special enough
to enact change with President Barbie and the
others having given into being housewives. So
our Barbie lays down and gives up. To escape
the macho madness that Barbieland has become,
Gloria, Sasha, and Barbie hide at Weird
Barbie's compound. Gloria gives Barbie a
dramatic and heartfelt speech about the inherent
difficulty of being a woman and it snaps Barbie
out of her doldrums. The gang deprograms Author
Barbie and puts together an elaborate plan to
do the same to the other Barbies, one by
one. The liberated Barbies will distract
the Kens while Gloria gives the other Barbies
the talk that brings them back to their senses.
Step two of this plan is to systematically deflate
the Kens' egos and set them against one another,
continuing to hide in plain sight under the guise
of obedient housewives until the right time to
strike. Gosling's Ken is hurt by the sight
of his Barbie flirting with his arch-rival,
Simu Liu's Ken, leading the Kens to
go to literal war with each other.
The initial violence and brutality don't last for
very long, though. Ken's solo song "I'm Ken" seems
to strike a chord within all the other Kens,
as their dance-fighting becomes something more
collaborative. In spite of themselves, they've
stumbled upon the solidarity and brotherly love
their short-sighted existences had been missing
out on this entire time. The war now over,
Barbieland reverts to normal — with
some added concessions for the Kens.﻿﻿
When Barbie
first gets to the real world, she's horrified
to discover its patriarchal structure. Ken,
however, isn't scared of it. He's elated. After
getting a bunch of library books about the
patriarchy from the library, he fails to get an
important job for the simple reason he is a man.
"But I'm a man."
"But not a doctor."
"Can I talk to a doctor?"
"You are talking to a doctor."
Ken thus decides that the real
world is doing patriarchy wrong,
and he needs to take those ideas
somewhere new to fully realize them.
So he functionally takes over Barbieland, teaching
all the other Kens to subjugate their respective
Barbies. They turn the dream houses into man
caves. The choreographed disco parties become
acoustic guitar covers of Matchbox Twenty's
"Push." The Kens convince every Barbie to stop
being a girlboss and just pass her boy a brewski.
The Kens throw out the constitution and corrupt
everything Barbieland once was, much to Barbie's
chagrin when she returns with Gloria and Sasha.
Once the Barbies distract the Kens to
reinstate their constitution and return
Barbieland to its former splendor, Ken
still doesn't know who he is or where he
belongs. He realizes he lost his enthusiasm
for patriarchy when he discovered it didn't
involve horses to the degree he once imagined.
Barbie apologizes for the way she treated Ken,
but has to caution him that this isn't
a happy romantic ending for the two of
them. She says he needs to spend time and
energy defining his own place in this world
outside of trying to court her. President Barbie
agrees to give the Kens more representation in
their government. Meanwhile, the Mattel
execs who crossed the beach portal are
satisfied, agreeing to start producing
Gloria's idea for an Everyday Barbie.
Everyone gets some kind of conclusion they
find satisfying — that is, except for Robbie's
Barbie. She wonders aloud if there's anything
left for her to do, still feeling confused
and bothered by all she's experienced.
She still sees herself as too ordinary
and unexceptional to deserve the kind of happy
ending a movie like this is supposed to have.
But that's when Ruth Handler, the creator of
Barbie, played by RheaPearlman, appears. She's
essentially God in Barbieland, and she offers
Barbie some holy counsel. Handler talks to Barbie
about the true nature of life and death, along
with what it means to be a human. Moved by all
this, Barbie asks if she can be a human too. But
after all she's endured on this quirky adventure,
she finds she already is.
In the film's final moments, Barbie goes with
Gloria and her family to some important event,
with the tenor of the scene suggesting this will
be her first day at her first human job, perhaps a
gig working at Mattel as a creative. Her earlier
monologue implied that could be on the horizon.
But for the film's final joke, her destination
is revealed to be a gynecologist's office.
"Here I go."
At numerous points in the film, characters
including Mattel's CEO, Weird Barbie,
and Ruth the creator offer up crucial
pieces of lore laden with the burning
necessity for follow-up questions, only to hand
wave them away. So when the film concludes with
Barbie turning from a doll to a real human
being, Ruth's phrasing implies that this
last climactic moment wasn't alchemy, but rather
the final act of a transformative character arc.
Barbie goes from being a one-dimensional and
idealized toy whose world has never known
struggle, contradiction or the finality
that defines a human life to becoming a
thinking and feeling entity who endures the
full spectrum of existence all in a single
day. By pulling Barbie out of the fictional
and aspirational artifice she was born into
and placing her within our very real world and
all its complications, she ascends from dollhood
to womanhood, bearing the massive weight
her gender must shoulder to simply exist.
It's easier to believe Barbie became
human by virtue of magical transformation,
like Pinocchio, and that's a valid reading
of what happens. But it's also clear that a
more pragmatic explanation is just as valid.
Just like the true nature of Barbie's
final evolution, the uneasy relationship
between Barbieland and the real world is
interesting to ponder. We're told, initially,
that what happens to the dolls in Barbieland
is the direct result of what the kids in the
real world do during playtime. So why then, is
Mattel so afraid of a doll in the real world,
and why does that give Barbieland similar
power over reality? Before Barbie is a physical
plaything in the real world, she is an idea — a
big one — housed within a malleable plastic totem.
When Sasha lashes out at Barbie, all the
particulars of her scathing rant outline
the many ways that Barbie, the doll, shapes
reality. The doll has become an ideal that,
on some level, flesh and blood women must
be compared to. How can you compete with
an object designed to be perfect when
you're a human being who is, by nature,
imperfect? We shape popular culture, but we imbue
art and products with the power to shape us too.
So of course the figures scrubbed clean of all
our ungainly humanity bounce right back at us,
reshaping the world as we know it in ways
surprising and previously unimaginable.
It's also why the ideas Ken brings back from the
real world wreak so much havoc on Barbieland.
Barbieland's idyllic paradise is informed
entirely by a fragile barricade of lofty tenets,
utterly undone the moment they come into
contact with contradictory concepts from
the broken world that initially birthed
them. "Barbie," miraculously, is able to
expand upon the reflexive nature of the dream and
the dreamer, neither knowing who is truly asleep.
"Ideas live forever."
Given director Greta Gerwig's unbridled
enthusiasm for the brand and the film's
commercial success thus far, sequels to "Barbie"
are more a question of "when" rather than "if."
There are plenty of Barbies and Kens to follow
into their own similarly meta dramedy vehicles
that evolve from the blueprint set out in
the first film. Too many talented young
actors appear here for one of them to not
get another shot as their respective doll
identities. But with Mattel pledging to exploit
all the other toys in their massive IP toybox,
there may be a larger Mattel cinematic universe
that Barbie would merely be a player in.
How, exactly, could Barbie team up with
He-Man, or the cars from Hot Wheels,
or Rock 'Em Sock 'Em robots? If you've made it
this far and have already seen "Barbie," you know
that the doors are blown wide open for any manner
of tie-in to make some kind of emotional sense,
even if it’s found to be wanting in the logic
department. Barbie could end up in Eternia
and the right combination of winking, nodding,
and sharply employed '80s or '90s needle drops
on the soundtrack will smooth over any rockiness
between the various brands' respective identities.
Reviews of "Barbie" have called it movie of the
summer, as well as one of the best of the year,
highlighting Gerwig and co-writer
Noah Baumbach's script as well
as her direction. But where will
things go next? Robbie told Time,
"It could go a million different
directions from this point."
Gerwig expressed enthusiasm about a potential
"Barbie" franchise in an interview with Variety,
but there are no solid plans. Whether
or not Gerwig herself will return to
the director's chair is a more difficult
call, given the rumors around her and the
"Narnia" universe over at Netflix, but a
more tantalizing question is whether the
Barbieverse will cross over with
another toy-birthed franchise.
This summer, we've already seen that Hasbro
and Paramount's twin-toy juggernauts "GI Joe"
and "Transformers" are joining forces, and
we know Mattel and Hasbro are buddy-buddy
enough when it comes to mutually
beneficial licensing opportunities;
they're even planning a Barbie Monopoly
game. Who's to say the "real world"
Barbie has entered isn't the same one
with robots that turn into cars and
stealth ninjas working with independent
military contractors to fight terrorism?
"Yeah, I'm…confused about that."